bienvenue dans le canton de saint denis
dans sa ville centre au coeur de
l'espace des trois frontières franco
germano suisse de l'agglomération
trinationale de bâle alors nous sommes
devant le forum
un équipement récent imposant avec une
belle signature architecturale
emblématique non seulement pour la ville
de saint louis qui en a fait un bâtiment
phare mais aussi pour tout le canton du
sud alsace
c'est une réalisation qui a mobilisé
plusieurs partenariats dont le
département du haut rhin pour compléter
l'offre en matière d'équipement
associatif événementiel et sportif il
est vrai que nous sommes dans un
territoire où la vie associative
culturelle et sportive est
particulièrement diversifiée et intense
de nombreux clubs sportifs évolué à un
haut niveau et stimule la pratique
sportive de toutes les générations
cet équipement répond tout simplement à
cette vitalité et au besoin d'outils
fonctionnelle de proximité pour
accueillir dans de bonnes conditions les
grandes manifestations sportives quelle
qu'elle soit
tout public ou pour des rassemblements
plus professionnel cet équipement était
la hauteur des besoins et aussi à la
dimension du rayonnement dans le sud
alsace et au et par-delà également des
frontières avec ce forum c'est lui c'est
donner une nouvelle identité en phase
avec la dynamique économique locale les
grands projets d'aménagement de grande
envergure vont impacter la vie
quotidienne de tous les habitants du
canton
parmi les grands projets en cours ou à
venir la question de la mobilité prend
une place majeure puisqu'il s'agit de
réorganiser tous les modes de
déplacements et du trafic autour des
pôles économique et résidentiel alors
sur ce plan la collaboration
intelligente avec nos voisins allemands
et suisses notamment est indispensable
parce que notre canton est un carrefour
un carrefour emprunté par des milliers
de véhicules au quotidien à la croisée
des grands axes de circulation de
transports internationaux
tous les chemins mènent aux cantons de
st lui toutes les infrastructures toutes
les voies de communication sont
présentes aéroportuaire ferroviaire
autoroutières et fluviales la mobilité
douce qui a également toute sa place
puisque nous sommes traversés par trois
axes eurovélo qui permettent à tous les
cyclistes de découvrir nos espaces
partagés
les projets en lien avec la mobilité
s'inscrivent forcément dans une vision
transfrontalière globale cohérente et
durable de l'aménagement du territoire
au quotidien ce sont trente quatre mille
personnes qui passent la frontière pour
aller travailler en suisse dans une
grande majorité en voiture dans cet
espace de grande circulation
chacun doit y trouver sa place et les
nécessaire de développer encore
davantage les transports collectifs et
l'intermodalité pour un environnement de
qualité propice à l'activité à la
création de richesses à l'emploi les
intérêts communs ont bien été identifié
avec nos partenaires suisses allemands
et des projets communs partagés se sont
engagés d'extension du tram bâlois vers
la gare de st louis en est un bel
exemple
le chantier est en phase d'achèvement et
il est prévu de le prolonger jusqu'au
futur parc euro 3 lys qui sera lui-même
desservi par un nouvel aménagement
routier et autoroutier
nous avons présent franchi les portes du
forum pour découvrir très nette en pole
le nouveau rendez vous de l'emploi des
métiers de la formation dans le sud
alsace tous les acteurs engagés dans
cette opération ont souhaité illustrer
la vitalité du territoire en proposant
la population une rencontre avec les
entreprises de pointe de l'agglomération
de saint louis mais aussi d'allemagne et
de suisse celle qui recrutent qui
cherchent de nouvelles compétences et
souhaite se faire connaître au total une
centaine d'entreprises et de
professionnels sont présents sur ce
forum pour présenter leurs atouts leur
opportunité d'emploi mais aussi tous les
dispositifs d'alternance et
d'apprentissage
les jeunes sont invités à échanger avec
les professionnels dans une démarche de
découverte des métiers et d'orientation
j'ai souhaité faire un petit focus sur
cet événement qui à mon sens c'est une
belle opportunité pour valoriser
l'attractivité du canton de saint louis
ces atouts relever les défis de l'emploi
de la formation et surtout préparer
l'avenir